tendance discuter joa [ __ ] aux jeux de
retour avec ainsi priya bonjour site
rien salus cuisine pourquoi on est avec
ses prix aujourd'hui parce qu'on va lire
tous les deux une fanfiction un qui est
en fait une fiction écrit par un fan
comme son nom l'indiqué jeu captain
obvious bonjour on va lire tous les deux
alors moi j'ai dû auront rédigé donc je
suis spoil mais lui il n'est pas encore
les gens et j'ai rien lu de lui n'a rien
vu c'est forcément un truc et qq
sexuelles non non non non l'hydro
cyprien lisons ces partis à la lutte le
comédien français gilles allais la
comédie chapitre 1 je dois lui avouer ça
fait une bonne heure que je suis devant
mon pc est éteint
je pense trop pas lui à ce que je
ressens pour lui pourtant j'aime les
filles du moins je crois
il a toujours été là pour me soutenir et
ça me touche beaucoup mes sentiments
envers lui on grandit de jour en jour
lui aussi sera avec des filles donc je
suis sûr de me prendre un taux de sa
part si jamais je suis à vous mes
sentiments oui là que mon téléphone au
on amène aussi mme bernigaud paris
allo elle salue lucas me dit il salut ça
va super et toi me demande-t-il beaucoup
mieux merci à tant mieux ça te dit de
manger une bonne pizza devant un film
tous les deux me propose t-il
ah oui pourquoi pas super à ce soir 19h
chao d'éthyle et il a raccroché
on va être que tous les deux et je sens
que je vais bégayer rougir toute la
soirée je vais me changer mettre un jean
et un simple t-shirt iron man ça fera le
faire je sors de chez moi et me dirige
vers ma voiture direction l'appartement
de cyprien
je n'arrive je tiens plus en place comme
si j'attendais un cadeau alors que c'est
lucas j'attends la sonnette de la porte
et me dirige vers celle ci j'ai louvre
et lui sourit il aborde sur les
craquants entre n'attend pas que je te
le dise tu tu es comme chez toi lui
dis-je la merde a à z
oui merci pardon il s'installe sur le
canapé et je lui montre sur ma télé les
films à voir
le connaissant il va vouloir regarder à
nouveau refait avec genre ça dérange pas
nous demande-t-il en me regardant de ses
magnifiques yeux bleus
non non t'inquiète pas dis-je en allant
chercher les pizzas on commence alors le
film tout en dévorant de pizzas et la
soirée ne fait que commencer
chapitre 2 même t-il le film est terminé
comme par hasard lucas est scotché à son
téléphone je dis ça mais moi aussi je
suis accro alors je fais de même sauf
que mon regard est est ce que tu es
resté pardon sauf que mon regard est
resté scotché sur lucas qui par moments
vous regarde furtivement d'un air gêné
puis rigide ce à l'heure où tu le
règlement craque
quand j'y pense il faudrait que je suis
pour bien-être des mois et lucas ouais
je t'ai pas dit mais mélanie et moi
c'est terminé
je suis désolé bros le truc du broc
rabat on tient au s'inquiète c'est moi
qui ai mis fin à notre relation
bah ouais je peux savoir pourquoi alors
là je ne m'y attendais pas dugas hochart
je me suis je comprends mieux maintenant
creek au pardon alors là je m'attendais
pas lucas au chat je suis obligé de
documents tiens tu ne veux pas lui dire
que je laime alors qu'il est hétéro et
qu'il me dira non ah oui bah je ne
l'aimé plus
ah d'accord adacore tesla et les
barriques watts et je ne pense pas qu'il
est qu'il est je pense pas qu'il ait
gober mais tant pis je ne suis pas prêt
à lui avouer mes sentiments
j'ai du mal à y croire
cyprien se séparer de mélanie après tant
de temps passé ensemble c'est juste un
gars génial pour moi c'est une véritable
porte qui s'ouvre je me concentre à
nouveau sur mon téléphone faisant mine
de regarder des trucs le regard de
cyprien est insistant ce qui me gêne
énormément et me fait rougir
il n'arrêtera donne jamais de me
regarder ou quoi ces prêts aspects
relatifs de me fixer cette plaie du but
philippe et là oh pardon
bravo lucas maintenance étendue entre
nous je suis dois je regarde à mon tour
mais furtivement le cas via un tweet qui
nous concerne montre je me colle à lui
pour regarder le tweet qui veut montrer
mais il est un écran je relève la tête
pour lui faire une remarque mais nos
élèves ne sont plus qu'à quelques
centimètres l'île de l'autre je rougis
énormément suite à ce rapprochement
sa main vient se glisser sur ma joue ses
lèvres se rapproche dangereusement de
mois et viennent se poser sur les
miennes je ne recule pas au contraire
j'aime bien intensifier ce baiser en
mettant mes mains sur son coup il se
retirer mais y regarde d'un air
interrogateur que tu ne pars en vous et
tu tues mais tu m'aimes je lui répondis
par un tendre baiser qu'il approfondit
un volant de corps l'un à l'autre puis
on se sépare à contrecoeur
cyprien depuis que tu célibataire on
s'est beaucoup rapproché très vite
courage en sortie des sentiments à ton
égard je t'aime
voilà ils regardent avec beaucoup de
tendresse
mais pour avoir ses bras aux enceintes
est dans mon cours ni déposant aussi un
doublé
c'est quoi cette phrase de m la soirée
se termine doucement je reste dormir
chez lui on part se coucher
je retire tous au fond qu'à son tee
shirt comme l'est d'ailleurs on
s'allonge et nous collons l'un à l'autre
rando laissant guider dans les bras de
morphée fin chapitre iii en cours
d'écriture
mais que va-t-il se passer par la suite
abonnez vous